mistakes are really important mistakes
are really valuable if you leave you
alive trying to run away from the
mistakes that you make you'll never
learn anything and you just play it safe
and you never do anything that's the
kind of person who doesn't ever make
mistakes
people who know take risks it's a boring
life his life doesn't shave very much
okay it's important that you give these
a shot and get wrong let's have a look
at seven minus five x equals a1 that'd
be a step that we could do first that
would help here any suggestions okay all
right bye Jamie
I think getting rid of this stuff is a
great idea right I'm gonna write this
down a second big me on the phone longer
being campaign you're working with mine
I'm gonna say it a little bit of a
different way though right I'm gonna and
I'm gonna encourage you to think about
it this way as well
right thinking about moving this guy
Obama being that this is an equation
like this is a statement that says this
thing and this thing are the same
they're equal they're identical they
have the same value okay baby you've got
that picture in your head you should
think about doing the same thing to both
sides because they're both the same
right try to think less about like
moving things here and there and it's
very confusing and you could end up with
something wrong and you don't know why
so instead of saying I'm gonna take
seven to the other side I'm going to
subtract 7 from both sides and that'll
get me somewhere okay so just follow
along with me I'll do it over here over
from the left I'll get negative 5x and
on but I'll get a minus 7 which is prime
okay so I think we're comfortable in
that right now pause at this point you
could probably say all right now I see
something's gone wrong what should I do
now actually get inside
yeah good okay now instead of taking
minus five to the other side what's the
actual operation then I yeah very good
so I want division to get from the side
to the next right in fact I'll even
write it here like so doc divided both
by negative five and they see exactly
what I mean by okay
rather than saying I'll take it to the
other side which kind of sounds the same
for both these operations I'm doing a
different thing here than a different
thing than that this year does that make
sense like when the fire goes over like
does it become a plus or a minus you can
see this is some really easy mistake to
make
I've made this mistake before okay but
now we know where it came from
cancel cancel x equals now 1 divided by
minus 5 that is the answer but we tend
since what's the negatives either on the
top or kind of like in the middle like
that it does not really matter whether
it's here or there it's a bit awkward to
divide by negative numbers because when
I think about like but I think about
number like this
right okay I've got a I've got three
things and then I want to share it to
four people that kind of makes it so you
each get three quarters of a piece but
what I think I've got one thing I don't
want to share it and negative five
people it's like yeah yeah you might not
have any friends but don't you say you
have like negative friends
so so therefore putting the number
between the negative on the key I have
named your friends I'm putting the
negative on the top that kind of makes
sense because then it's like I have I've
lost something and that's what I need to
share out or alternatively pretty here
because it's like an operation that
applies to don't know is it does that
make sense okay I'm so glad we had that
discussion this one is missing I don't
want to know what the answer is I
who attempted it heads up keep your hand
up if you have an answer
keep your hand up if you think you're
reasonably confident the answers right I
can get it out next time
you ten people should have covered to
the bottom written this down okay now a
lot of people didn't write it so let's
have a crack and I won't do it I'm
really supposed to say this was
something else so write this hanging
after we're done here but I'm going to
do the working for that question
okay now everything like I said it's a
bit of football so I understand people
we've been saying this whole time like
over here and stuff like that where you
can you should avoid a fracture I take
it that's why most of you said for here
the first step is probably take away
seven right that makes sense if you
divide by 5 to get fractions everywhere
ok thumbs up however here you're kind of
stuck because I just hand you a faction
right from the get-go right so being
that is a fraction or yeah is there any
way that I can get through there okay
number one I could change into 0.5 and
that would be fine and then I could like
so trying to add all that company and
that's that's fine in fact I'm gonna do
the working for that in a second
but there's another way I can actually
just like simplify just another way of
writing huff it's still the same number
can I change it actually in any way that
I don't have to deal with fractions or
decimals at all any takers
yeah good I've got a half of it if I
multiply everything by two which is fine
this is an equation of its balance but
do something the left and the right
everything comes out law this fraction
will know okay so I'm gonna take this
and if you've got this written down
somewhere I would encourage you to put
brackets around this this is my bracket
language I use for shorthand I'm gonna
put to the front and then I'm gonna
multiply this guy by two so I'll
multiply both sides by two
once you've done that like this
expanding brackets you've done this
loads right you just take each of those
multiply them by 2 so what's on the left
hand side and then 2 miles better me one
right now that there
I've taken a problem which we were very
confident with it and we're like bit
iffy about it and I've turned into this
and you guys have seen dozens of these
problems you're pretty good at them so
now let's go ahead and solve it what
should I do
I should subtract 4 from both sides one
take away 4 is going to be negative 3
and my last step is kind of where the
fraction now I should divide by age
right divided by 8 so now to give me
just X by itself over there and minus 3
are you happy
okay so let's talk about let's talk now
about like how should I write my answer
because this comes up for a question
like this that's minus 0.375 I think it
comes up for a question like this and
yes that is a three it's just a small
three okay the question came out to be
like Oh which one should I put as the
answer should I put that or should I put
a decimal should I put a what we call
this one they've got different names
this is an improper fraction and this is
a big skier off because we mixed
together a hold on Verona and a function
okay um what do you put no just for
question one you could put this now you
might have heard in the past hey you
should really make sure you put it in
this one or you've heard some other
people say Paige really crispy
disappoint right
and some of you're like well which one
should I do if all you want is a
valuable because in the same number
that's what it is okay however there are
some circumstances where this is kind of
more helpful more useful to us the myths
okay for example if I ask you to do a
graph right in fact we'll do this when
we get to you know anyway they have one
at the moment and two then three and the
HSC even get to a and five and four we
have to look at a lot of straight lines
things like this okay and you have to
like read them you have to interpret it
so long as suppose I wanted me to find
out what this number was and the answer
you got back was 19 over 3 okay now if
you want to know it accurately wait you
should put this thing you got
scale and you think okay well there's
you know all these different numbers
labeling here I have no way to you in
1908 three years I didn't memorize
things in thirds whereas when I see six
and a third up it's kind of between six
and seven and closer to the snakes like
I have a handle on it where that's
supposed to be right so that's why this
form of number kind of makes more sense
if you try to do something with this so
you know how we see the word life
simplified you see the what in that's
right
simplified depends on like what's it law
depends on what you're going to do later
with that normal like that no it's gonna
go somewhere you might have to do
something with it and different things
different purposes you see different
numbers okay when we get to the next up
we have exercise I'll show you some
times when actually you know what this
kind of is a bit more pain don't do it
like that it's just gonna be a hassle
for you you might as well leave it like
this okay so some of you will have your
work be read about this before there's
no clear winner in this case because
remember I said like the numbers going
somewhere this numbers not going
anywhere so we don't know what you want
to use it for so we don't know which one
is best
okay so therefore any form is fine is
that it
my survey can we some fly to Miami for
you okay that's a good question so I'll
come back to this one to illustrate the
answer the dress okay I remember I said
either of these are fine and he's fine
I'll tell you what's not fired 19 over 3
and 38 over 6
those are two fractions they have the
same value okay but 38 over C just one
okay why not yeah it's not I can do
better than that right once you get to
90 over 3 that's kind of as far as you
can go and I think that we call the
prime numbers you can't divide it by
anything except for 19 and 1 so
therefore that's clearly this is clearly
a step backwards right this is not as
good okay in the same way we're having
look at this if I had written instead
minus 1.5 over okay it's something we've
got fractions but we also have ingest
some flying around like why would you do
that you're just kind of making more
awkward whereas these are all whole
numbers that's kind of the best I can do
me that I have a fraction so I would
leave it like this and I don't think
there's any field benefit to changing
this now just before they discussion the
last thing that gossips I didn't answer
was can I leave my in size this can I do
that and that's fine the answer I'm
gonna give is again it depends on where
you're going right like what is this
nothing but going to be useful if you
are trying to do like a blood alcohol or
something like that that's a pretty bad
I think
those numbers often oh yeah it's like
you have someone to alkalize anyway the
point is that those numbers are always
given is its estimate right so therefore
it makes sense to provide answers also
in decibel I'm just trying to think
about it because we will get the child's
dosage of medicine working also in
decimals by new measures oh yeah I'm
gonna have three and a fifth of a milk
no one does it right so therefore that
kind of except again based on the
context we're not asked this question
again unit secretly huskier what are you
using the number for then you learn how
to provide it right that was there was
their answer for this and x equals two
is fine
some people are true looked at this and
didn't know what to do didn't know where
to start
yeah that's again let me quickly show
you right again what we're trying to do
is get the next get the pretty room by
himself
okay now most people probably realize I
should get that twelve over the other
side he's in the wedding but they're
what I do with these X somebody a lot of
you didn't have your hands up so you
knew what to do
what would you do with this X yeah yeah
I'm going to now again language language
right I am going to take the other side
but what am i doing to get it to the
other side I'm going to but I'm gonna
subtract X from both sides right so if I
subtract an X from both sides that's why
it leaves you with six over here no X's
over here cuz I've taken that away and
when you add 12 to both sides there you
go you can see where x equals two
yeah how did you do it did you take the
seven year I guess you used to practice
evidence and that's five in some ways
it's like okay that way you don't have
to move this guy anywhere but I guess we
generally put this on the left that's
the only way